annan foi outra estrela foi pela estrela
é preciso trazer o sol aqui quem fala é
o dado que seja muito bem vindo de
xangai de um vídeo e o estrago jec na
série friends 4 é muito ruim da lua me
disse vocês criam para continuar não vou
fazer agora que um curso com vocês que a
sucos que passar esta noite agora neste
vídeo eu vou continuar se não conseguir
não quero nunca mais te ver este é o
menu é um menino extremamente bonito ao
qual o substantivo habituado porque o
tesouro começa a ser usada daqui eu não
posso deixar entrar em turno mário né ai
jesus
a itália usando um termo lavabos à porta
fechada
obrigado também ao pessoal que me ajudou
os ossos embora não a ele está porque ai
para para para que a haja sair foi a
emenda o que entrou que vem com um
rendimento de buscar tudo buscar eu não
sei eu não sei que vou fazer a minha
vida está aqui emendou nem aí com o fred
me concentrar mais né assim o café está
fraco hoje eu fui pra onde agora 11
esquerda direita e esquerda direitos que
eram o novo disco tem comigo as coisas
que sinto uma vibração sinto um pouco a
portar no momento em que vocês estão tão
ouvir está tudo bem está tudo bem tudo
tranquilo barulho quando os discos que
me conformar com a frase eu estava
falando sério mesmo com formato fredes
mas no entanto não era esta casa tipo
outra casa qualquer nem sequer a mim era
uma casa abandonada não sai e itaqui o
jacques diof lanternas e eu acho que
agora é a casa era uma casa boa renda eu
não sei casa era que ela estava toda a
partida e ventava higiene eletrônicos
também não eram isso era um outro sabe
aquela sensação quando vocês são
comerciais e eu bem que eu não consegue
ouvir nada é isso que eu estou sentindo
estou falando não houve nada ai meu deus
não está bem é será que eu consegui
passar esta noite ou não eu espero que
sim
ai ai ai
já não é que o fei como ninguém o sabe
tudo o que escrevo está também mas já
com sua ópera la pela janela mas como
ela é o meu amigo imaginário porque eu
falo sozinho em casa e eu falo com manel
ataque agora fecha a porta e ouviu um
armário abrir meu 200 grupos aproveita
sempre quando eu vou ver a porta
esquerda - herói nestas pela que traz
aquela ter ganho os preços pelos lados
do espectro
estamos na noite mais uma noite 31 messi
mas é essa
as pessoas perguntam da arca do gosto da
área caiu sim adoro adoro eu não faço
isso que vocês pedem eu adoro adoro eu
gostar aqui fazer não está aqui ninguém
a cair outra vez para lá fui pra lá pra
ela precisa entrar na casa eu era meia
noite e agora tenho uma pulseira do
atleta fred góes five night frete casa e
precisa mais tempo calada insistiu que
existe concentração estrela e eu sei que
sou uma pessoa concentrada quando um
concentro 15 rico não por mais 40 cópias
porque é um concentrado não ta ai ai na
porta
oi oi o game de aventura mario autor o
fazer isto não vá ainda não tá lá e
agora o barco vai para a esquerda
mesmo a cair na água e ficar com calma
muita calma tá tranquilo aqui é preciso
acabar com aquela que é o preocupante é
o faz sempre na esquerda
ai ai não foi pra direita é preciso de
ver karnak ainda como é que é possível
ok são três da manhã
estou aguentando muito bem e já não
sendo aquela nã esquerda é na esquerda
acho que está aqui fecha a porta está
aqui por semana agora embora a direita
linho e acho que daí houve qualquer
coisa e acho que ele nem eu acho que o
menino agora eu ainda não agora
ai eu não cantar não não
pessoal vamos ficar com os filhos para
que vocês tenham gostado e eu não vou
parar os carros da google edition fünf
frades fórum são 431 sair e não voltar a
jogar estar nessas redes porque não não
dá pra usar é possível e é isso ai é
favorito e faz um comentário do tipo eu
gosto dos senhores com o pato agridoce é
isso que os portugueses na bunda rua e
até a próxima